[Music]
so Santa Claus we don't have any
Neanderthal DNA so we don't have any DNA
in common well that's not entirely true
let's go slowly there we have found no
mitochondrial DNA it found a very small
amount of nuclear DNA but the important
point is that mitochondrial DNA
Nanoka mitochondrial DNA is missing from
human DNA right the mitochondrial DNA is
DNA that's found is what is called the
mitochondria mitochondria is a so are
subunits of the cell that processed food
you know when you eat what what these
subunits do they convert that food into
energy that your body can use okay
that's what it is and the important
thing about that it's not so much you
know what it is because people don't
really have to know they need to know is
that mitochondrial DNA comes from the
mother in mammals especially in common
is it comes from the mother in others
the mother passes mitochondrial DNA to
her children not the father
there's no mitochondrial DNA from
father's we inherit 100% of it from
mothers so if we happen not to find
nano-thermite the kind of DNA in humans
well that's kind of odd wouldn't it be a
meaning for for the admitster theory how
similar that mixture yeah and Mister
theory says that you know humans mated
with Neanderthal some 40 to 80 thousand
years ago and we are their offspring the
end of those did not become extinct they
became us so we populated them
supposedly this is the theory and
not that we have a fact on this but this
is the theater theory is that humans
emerged from Africa they went into
Europe encountered Neanderthals and we
had a ten to one ratio population ratio
ten ten humans for everyone and Eartha
we were much more numerous okay and that
because of this the nfl's eventually you
know dissolved into our population okay
so NASA really did not become extinct he
just mated with us and you know such a
smaller group that their their
contribution to our DNA was much smaller
and then over the years we lost some of
them we ended up with what little we
have today how was this happen what does
this have to do with this problem well I
define it has to do with the
mitochondrial DNA because we found no
mitochondrial DNA no no no though
mitochondrial DNA in humans none
whatsoever
I mean let me let me read a couple of
articles here that show clearly that you
know there there was none these are all
published articles by the way the
Neanderthal sequence this is cranes 1997
the Nana Thal sequence falls outside the
variation of modern humans the Nana
thoughts went extinct without
contributing mitochondrial DNA to modern
humans claims 1999 look at the dates
also on all this this is just two years
later the Neanderthal mtDNA is found to
fall outside a phylogenetic tree
relating the empty DNA's amount of
contemporary humans the results support
the concept that the Nana thaw mtDNA
evolved separately from that of modern
humans for a substantial amount of time
and lends no support to the idea that
they contributed mitochondrial DNA to
contemporary modern humans any
mitochondrial DNA check out mm they're
empty DNA types have not contributed to
the modern human
ene Poole Schultz mm the MT DNA
sequences provided by cranes and the
data presented here indicate a clear
differentiation of mandibles and
anatomically modern human and modern man
and support the assumption that both
taxa are discrete species there are
different species this also means that
anitha's cannot be the direct ancestor
of anatomically modern man here we have
Sarah 2000 for the retrieval of
mitochondrial DNA sequences from for
Nana the fossils has demonstrated that
these individuals carry closely related
mitochondrial DNA s that are not found
among current humans there's noone in
2006 the maximum likelihood estimate for
the Nana thought contribution the mother
genetic diversity is zero none green
2008 two years later analysis of the
assembled sequence unequivocally
establishes that the Neanderthal DNA
falls outside the variation of extant
human mtDNA is LC saying the same thing
- yeah agreed 2010 the only part of the
genome that has been examined from
multiple Nana Thals
the mitochondrial DNA genome
consistently falls outside the variation
found in present-day humans and thus
provides no evidence for interbreeding
and then we have the Guru of genetics of
Neanderthal genetics Santa Paula that
Nobel conference 2014 it's very clear
that there is no one running around
today with a mitochondrial mitochondrial
genome of an animal so there has to be
that consensus there's a total consensus
none of these tests why do they make so
many of them and that's the point the
point is that you would think that after
two or three tribes people would have
given up and say well yeah there's no
microphone and I thought mitochondrial
DNA in humans the point here is that
this is all politics
they're trying at all costs and against
all odds trying to prove admixture and
when they found that there's no
mitochondrion
we'll run another test maybe maybe the
next one shows a little bit they rang
another one they didn't find anything is
it run another one run another one run
on that way they run so many because
they were trying to find evidence to
prove their improvement their foregone
conclusions which is admixture because
we don't have any it's very hard to
support admission theory because it
means that we all our mothers were human
mothers and that's nobody's challenging
to you bath but we had known and Athan
mothers we only have manifold father's
and that's very hard to see very
opposite but it gets worse because they
run another test another study and this
is on the y chromosome now there's women
have this is a sexual chromosome X X and
males have X Y the Y is only passed from
father to son yeah so Y chromosome only
goes from father to son it turns out the
study shows that we have no y
chromosomes from the Neanderthals we
only have human Y chromosome so Y
chromosome from humans don't match of
nano so you men have DNA from human yeah
no we only have Y chromosomes from
humans right no DNA comes from women why
can't girls always come from men so we
only had human mothers and we only had
human fathers kind of like that and
here's a study at Mendes 2016 the Y
chromosome divergence mirrors the
population divergence of Nanda Thals and
modern human ancestor we refused
alternative scenarios of a relatively
recent or super archaic origin of
Neanderthal white chromosomes the Navajo
why has never been observed in modern
humans the lineage is most likely
distinct in other words we have
inherited no y chromosomes
so like you said you know we have no we
had a men had no ethical fathers and we
own all of us we only had yeah both on
Mother's well you know that's like human
mothers that's so it's like you know
what do we say here you know wait so how
do they push that mixture if there's so
much evidence
well they explain it away yes here I
researched a little bit find out what
kind of answers they need and why we
lacked the this the DNA and I'll just
read about when it says its genetic
drift that means that over the centuries
we just lost this DNA right over time
the second one the hybrid boys did
survive to bequeath the Y chromosomes
now I think's right yeah that means the
the kids who are a product of both
species somehow did not survive the boys
the boys did not survive only the female
survives or no boys survive yeah they're
trying to explain it away right
the third my incompatibility of
mitochondrial DNA between the two
species that means that we did not
inherit any mitochondrial DNA from
Neanderthal females because theirs was
incompatible with our DNA and so that
part was lost but we kept the ones that
were came from our human females so wait
the children of Neanderthal females
didn't have the DNA no they had the DNA
but they somehow they it was
incompatible with ours and when they
died they they just took it with them
that's what they're saying and then
there's another the dying out of the
original population of humans that
interpret
this is unbelievable so we went to
Europe and we we all died in the new
humans came in yeah you don't ask me you
ask them this question the children of
the Neanderthal mother's state state
with a clan and died out with them in
other words if a mother if I'm and Athan
mother had a boy or a girl for that
matter those kids stayed with a
Neanderthal clan if human mother had a
kid with a Neanderthal that kids stayed
with us so it turns out we inherited
only from the mothers human mothers and
we did not inherit from the Navajo
mothers because all that vineyards
eventually died out that's what that's
one explanation and then another another
one that I gathered that many more nanda
thought males had sex with human females
than human males with hadatha females in
other words the net worth all males had
a lot of sex with our females and we had
very little with their freedom they
don't make sense either because well it
would that's that's what they're trying
to explain here in other words what
they're saying but they're say here yeah
I doubt nobody's claimed them I don't
know but it wouldn't explain why we
don't have any y chromosomes no no
because remember it's only the females
that survive not the males so the nedeth
all male had sex with our females
yeah which were you know they were
cheating on us it's a very sexist theory
in training and and and they had kids
but the male's did not survives the
females that survived me they brought it
all the way to us why are they so so
convinced that admixture is the reason
the end-result night off is it is it
just that they can't think of a better
one if if admixture dies they really
don't have an explanation for the
extinction of the Neanderthals that's
the like I said in earlier you know 90
to 99 percent of the theories are
founded humans didn't somehow being
responsible for the disappearance of the
Neanderthals and if we remove humans
from the equation there is no there
there is nothing and so so they're
putting all their eggs in one basket
that we had something to do with it and
the main one within that is that we had
sex with Evan had children and that they
simply disappeared because not very
populated then you have populated them
and their genes got diluted over the
centuries in our bigger population uh so
what do you think of geneticists who say
that your great-grandmother slept with a
gander thought well let me tell you what
I think come on up
[Music]